Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
in the book of prayer
in the chapters regarding the timings of
prayer.
And here the author discusses
the ideal time to make salat
when did the prophet sallall.aii
Make now we've heard at the beginning of
this the book of prayer that the times
for
is from the break of dawn the true dawn
until the actual sun the the disc of the
sun becomes vis vvis visible over the
eastern horizon that's the time when it
is valid but what of the time is best
we've discussed the best time for the
best time for the best time and ideal
time for the ideal time for
now we are going to discuss the ideal
time for now how do we quantify that if
we don't have an exact narration
of our prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam saying the best time to make
fud is this time then how Can we
reach that conclusion? Well, we look at
the consistency of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. We might
find instances where he makes salah just
before the sunrise
and we may find instances where he makes
salah somewhere in the middle somewhere
in the beginning. Those are a those
instances
are
exceptions to the rule. They are because
of circumstance. Something happens. He
has to delay prayer. For instance,
he is receiving revelation just before
fud
and
we cannot interrupt this revelation. So
we wait for him. In the narration of Ib
Abbas, he was receiving revelation from
Allah where Allah showed him the cosmos.
Subhan Allah. And he said, Allah then
placed his hand
into my back between my shoulder blades
and I felt the coolness of that touch
all the way reverberating through the
front of my chest. and I was shown all
of the cosmos.
And so while this was happening, the
companions were in the masid waiting for
him to come out and start salah. And so
they waited and waited and waited until
just before sunrise he finally came out.
And this is called
this time of making.
And when he came out, he made and then
he informed them. This is a one-off. He
didn't always make at this time. So when
did he always usually make
[Silence]
so the author says
that it is preferred to make as early as
possible and at the very beginning of
its time. This is referred to as
when we make at the beginning of its
time. This is referred to as
okay. He then mentions a narration on
the authority of
[Silence]
and so
here she says that the women the
believing women the Muslim women in the
time of the prophet Sam
they used to flock to the masjid to make
with
and they would come wrapped up in their
garments
as hijab and they would make salah and
then they would all go back to their
homes without anyone recognizing them.
So even the other women and them walking
home in the streets, no one could see
who they were. What does this mean? It's
it's dark out. It's still dark. It's
very dark. And the only way that this
can happen if we combine that with the
length of his recitation.
it's highly unlikely
that most Muslim have ever been in a
salah for
that is the length of salah that the
prophet would usually make for sau
highly unlikely. Even the fud that we
prayed now many people would find this
to be long that's very long. The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam would
sometimes recite surah yuf in the first
and in the second how much is that
almost 30 pages a little bit more than
30 pages. This was average recitation
and this is what Omar was actually
reciting the morning that he was
attacked and and and murdered.
this is the length of prayer because
Allah says in the Quran specifically
recite in the prayers and especially
recite
extra long in the morning
because the salah is most witnessed by
the angels.
Right?
Salah is most witnessed by the angels
because every one of us, we have two
angels, right? One that is on our right
and writes our good deeds and encourage
us to do good things and one in our left
that writes down our bad deeds and
forbids us and warns us when we go to do
bad things.
But not just that, but there are two
shifts.
There are two in the morning during the
daylight hours and then there are two in
the evening during the nighttime hours.
So each one of us has how many angels
that write his deeds? Four angels. Now
when we go to make
what happens? The angels of the day come
down to take over from the angels of the
night.
And so for
specifically
all the angels for all of us are present
in the masid with us. They're all here
watching our deeds and praying with us.
And so
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala encouraged
strongly that fud be the lengthiest
recitation
because when a person recites the Quran
at in any salah, the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam says that there are
angels specifically
designated
to listen to the Quran from human beings
and then when a person stands for salah
and starts to recite the angel will
stand in front of him and come closer
and closer and closer and open its mouth
his mouth
and that every word recited
is recited directly into the angel's
belly.
Right? So he places his mouth on the
mouth of the recider
and all of the recitation goes into the
inside of the angel.
And so because of this the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam encouraged that
fud be the longest prayer. If we if we
take that along with is saying that
women would come to the fud and would go
home and it's still dark enough for them
not to be recognized. This means that he
was making fud when almost as soon as it
comes in almost as soon as it comes in.
Now remember the wording is ka
which is a word that means they used to
the prophet used to we used to meaning
this is words that are used to
articulate patterns meaning most of the
time this is how fud was there may be
some issues that arise that cause him to
delay fud
But his habit,
his
you know when he would usually make is
at the very beginning of its time. And
what is this called?
This is called
[Silence]
How you doing?
How are you? You okay?
[Arabic recitation]